yesterday on the view stormy Daniels and
her lawyer revealed a sketch of the do
two allegedly made threats in a parking
lot can we take a look at that track
with you oh there you go
and to your recollection is is that the
person that threatened you absolutely
how many years ago it was seven years
and you remember to that detail I mean
he looks like an actor sort of that's
why he stood out to us because I thought
honestly that he was you know sort of
handsome and well when I saw him when I
was parking I was like oh that's
somebody's husband you don't accuse
somebody but I want him the president
today responded to this saying a sketch
years later about a non-existent man a
total con job playing the fake news
media for fools but they know it his
tweet linked to a comparison in which a
Twitter user thinks there's a similarity
between the mystery man and Stormies
husband now before the media gets on
their high horse and tried to the
president for weighing in be aware that
every single media mouthpiece is doing
the very same thing the sketch invites
comparisons and in a circus like this
the circus made more absurd everyday by
media and legal hysterics it's just
another mad attraction that challenges
any decorum we have left after stormy
shows up in court as a publicity gimmick
and reveals the sketch on a morning gab
fest usually reserved for discussing
Kardashian's glutes it's hard to take
any of it seriously especially as the
president makes potentially historic
progress with North Korea so who's the
guy in the sketch is it this guy or that
guy or this guy I don't know and I'm
beginning to think that no one else does
either so I have to really know meet
Michael a vanetti is that I say it it's
Stormy's husband's lawyer as well
responded to Trump's tweet and I want to
read them and my experience is tweet one
in my experience there's nothing better
in litigation than having a completely
unhinged kind of an overused word
undisciplined opponent who is prone to
shooting himself in the foot always
leads to big lis problems like new
claims second tweets ie defamation
warning as the walls close and reality
sets in that the most damaging witness's
secrets and evidence are no longer
protected fully expect the following
sheer panic personal attacks tirades
distraction none of it will change the
outcome in the end hashtag faster all
right so I have to it's also some news
just in the Nadi's on another network
and saying that he's going to add a
defamation case against the president
United States there you go
so I have to give him credit Kimberly
this is now a meme it's like people have
Tom Brady they got Kato Kaelin they got
mark McGrath I saw one of you yes I did
too
yes that wasn't funny I'm not that
good-looking you ruin clothes though for
kill me by atome well obviously it
should be taken seriously if somebody
threatened her and said that you're not
- you know cooperate intimidation and
harass her to the point where she felt
she needs to be silenced till now
however nevertheless now you see it's on
the view and they're laughing about it
and he looks like an actor but yeah I
mean there are it's all over the
internet everybody making comparisons a
variety of people saying it looks like
them so quite frankly because it does
resemble so many different people as a
former prosecutor I'll tell you it makes
it very difficult what a great point oh
my that's a great point because you
disaster cuz it could be anybody so
let's just prosecute anybody yes that's
the problem so it's just rife with
problems in terms of identification
reasonable doubt but it looks like this
person are you sure the passage of time
inability to make a positive ID or a
cold show like we say I don't know I
mean what what are you gonna do it's out
it's good bill put it as Christmas cards
is it possible that the material that
they seized in Michael Cohen's raid and
his emails would lead them back to this
mysterious actor person well you know
what Dana anything is possible
meaning if there was the identity of a
person in fact he was acting in concert
and you know specified for someone to go
maybe you find them and I doubt the name
will be written in big bold print
somewhere but that's why you have to
have I think a special master like I did
in my case go through all of the
documents information you're not sure
that you get only what you're supposed
to do as well to uphold the
attorney-client privilege yeah but yeah
there could be a lot of variety of
different things in there that aren't
pertinent so good we have a prosecutor
here why do you have any theories
I know I know we need help later at some
point watch you have a theory I mean the
thing is everybody is now adding to this
because it's it's like guess who the guy
is if the guy exists you know I think
it's probably a publicity stunt I don't
know I think that Kimberly's right
though when people are being intimidated
in her ass we shouldn't dismiss it out
of hand right if it's stormy Daniels but
the thing that I'm I'm sorry even if
there's a passage of time yeah but the
thing that caught my attention Greg is
why is the president tweeting about this
how low can you go I don't like it I
just think you know my what are you
gonna do I mean you can't even if you if
I'm sure people tell about behavior by
the President of the United States first
of all he says they didn't happen so
leave her let it be but I mean I think
that was a good strategy on his part but
now he's tweeting about her and this bit
to me it's like a tawdry display it is
it is Jesse you don't think the
president can help himself yeah I think
we're beyond that point but I mean I get
that sex sells but it's the 15 minutes
has got to be up pretty soon this is
just about a non-disclosure agreement
that was allegedly broken a court should
just fast-track this someone's going to
get a judgment or they're gonna settle
that's it didn't make this want to go to
arbitration or go to arbitration forget
about it but when you pile up as you
said all these stunts from the sketch to
the photo of the lie-detector test to
the nationwide strip club tour so this
guy's all over every single cable outlet
and then it also they do yeah
the first of all the gut the lawyer is a
highly paid Democratic attorney who's
represented dozens of Democrats you team
him up with the publicity-seeking
porn star not saying these allegations
aren't accurate but and they go hand in
hand and when you have the media
assuring them along and acting like
she's pure as the wind-driven snow
it's a rep as a recipe for disaster they
don't ever ask her any challenging
questions they never debate her they
take everything she says as fact it's
beyond the point of no return at this
point it's about a campaign finance
violation Bernie Sanders just settled
the campaign finance violation for
$14,000 because he accepted donations
from Australia this is the exact same
type of violation and they raided the
president's lawyer's office over it in
President Obama's ass on even bigger
like when
right after he came in yeah something
like that but of course there was no
effort to conceal it yeah